- I feel like Stephen and
I might not be friends
after this video.
- That's because you
suck at arts and craft,
and I'm awesome.
(holiday music)
- [Voiceover] I think I
don't need the instructions.
- I could do this for days.
- I feel like a child, but it's fun.
- I'm already like done.
You said this would take 40 minutes,
I'm thinking five.
- Now I don't know what I'm doing at all.
- Nope, this is a disaster.
- Agghhh.
- Actually, I feel like
my girlfriend would enjoy
if we were sitting here together doing it.
- Well, she's not!
I can't be her Stephen!
- Oh no.
- That's what yours looks like!
- No, mine is clean.
- Mine looks pretty dope.
- This looks like sugar.
Okay, mine looks like crap.
- I have to say, it
turned out really nice.
- This reminds me of LeBron.
He does this thing, the "power-toss."
(blows forcefully)
- It looks like what it is,
which is you rolled salt onto a mason jar.
- [Voiceover] Ooh, mason jar lids.
- I'm actually so excited.
I've always loved hot glue guns.
- Oh, that's garbage.
- It's like once I make one mistake,
I'm like 'fuck it, I don't care anymore.'
But I do, I want this to look nice.
- I feel like this is taking
longer than it should.
- This is really fucking hard.
Who invented this stupid bullshit?
- I feel like the world's
shittiest Martha Stewart right now.
- How do reload this thing?
- What is it with these things and twine?
Why do they always wanna make us--
- What do twine do?
- Ha, it's decent. Look.
- I can't look right now, I'm too busy.
- Sorry.
- They're adorable!
- They kind of are.
- I screwed it up,
but then I managed to
get it back on track.
- Stephen's is ugly.
- We are doing a 3D snowflake together.
Because Christmas is all about
getting along with each other.
- I don't have a good
feeling about this craft.
- What?
- I'm terrified.
- How?
- This is--
- I cut the first pieces of paper wrong.
- Disaster.
- Had to get new pieces of paper.
- Shameful.
- And have Matt show me
the right way to cut.
- Mmhmm, surprising.
- Alright, alright, we can do this.
- Ah, ahhh.
- What are you doing, what?
- I think buying IKEA furniture together
is easier than this.
(laughs)
- This could be in a museum.
- The shittiest, saddest museum.
- I don't understand how
you can be bad at cutting.
- You know, I don't understand
how you can be so mean
to someone so fuckin' cute.
Okay, that's very mature Stephen.
- Kind of looks like a
person, more than a snowflake.
- It's like a snowflake dancer.
- Maybe you can do it in like fast motion.
- He's available for parties,
ladies and gentleman.
- It turned out even
better than we expected.
- And this is like Picasso.
- You know it's always fun to do crafts,
but you forget how frustrating it is.
- Kate messed up a lot.
- I think it's cheaper,
and it means a lot more
when you do it.
- Stephen and I should do
Pinterest crafts every year.
'Cause clearly it works out great.
- You're welcome, America.
(laughs)
- And God bless us, everyone.
- Merry Christmas!
- Thank you.